[Musica]
sono paolo paolo miggiano scusate questi
fogli ma questi fogli servono per
contenermi dentro ai diciotto minuti
altrimenti vado fuori io diciamo che ho
due vite la prima è terminata anche se
sono ancora qui e durata 34 anni e
facevo il poliziotto una vita molto
entusiasmante perché facevo
l'elicotterista ho studiato qui in
questo palazzo l'ultimo piano preso il
brevetto da elicotterista qui
e questo il volo è stata la mia prima
grande una delle mie più importanti
passioni poi in questa quella attuale
non faccio più il poliziotto qualcuno mi
chiama scrittore
io per la verità non è che ci creda
molto perché ancora l'ansia la paura del
foglio in bianco non mi ha abbandonato
però credo di avere passione nello
scrivere e le storie che scrivo mi
appassionano mia persona certe storie e
non altre si avvicinano molto anzi sono
proprio le storie che rappresenta il
logo di tex io per la verità appunto non
so se ancora stesso scrivere forse mi
illudo ma io lo faccio lo faccio davvero
con compassione perché sono storie
particolari in italia lo sappiamo ci
sono le mafie in campania
ci sono le camorre e dove ci sono le
mafie e le camorre ci sono i soldi molti
soldi e i camorristi mafiosi per fare i
soldi sparano sparano e ammazza ed è una
guerra certo non è la guerra che ci ha
fatto vedere fausto prima di noi prima
di me comunque è una guerra è una guerra
con dei numeri impressionanti sono
migliaia i morti tra quelli che si
ammazzano tra di loro sono numeri
impressionanti sembrano i numeri di una
guerra e sono numeri che ci devono
interessare però poi ci sono anche gli
effetti collaterali di questa guerra e
sono le vittime innocenti
per la verità questa non è manco una
guerra perché una guerra la si dichiara
ma la maggior parte delle persone che
muoiono senza avere nulla a che vedere
senza azzeccarci nulla con la camorra
questa guerra non l'hanno dichiarata
quindi questa guerra c'è e basta
sapete quante sono in italia le vittime
innocenti sono almeno un migliaio e qui
nella nostra regione sono 350 tra questi
venticinque bambini
e allora spesso noi vediamo che si
racconta il male si raccontano le storie
dei mafiosi
per finire su un libro o su uno schermo
di un cinematografo su quello di una
televisione in questo paese tu devi
essere un mafioso
forse va un po meglio alle vittime
illustri falcone e borsellino ma gli
ultimi i dimenticati gli sconosciuti i
25 bambini non li racconta nessuno non
li narra nessuno ecco perché io c'ho la
passione per un'altra narrazione e mi
appassionano queste storie perché
appunto sono le storie dei dei vinti dei
più deboli di quelli che non hanno voce
a causa del crimine ecco io stasera qui
vi potrei raccontare davvero 350 storie
perché c'è un sito lo potete andare a
vedere
e lì abbiamo raccontato tutte in
fondazione polis e li trovate tutte le
storie di queste 350 persone
io questa sera ne ho scelto e due una è
la storia di un nostro conterraneo un
venditore ambulante
l'ambulante solo lo chiamo io perché in
un paese di pavidi di corrotti di
faccendieri egli seppe resistere e poi è
la storia
l'altra è quella di una bambina una
bambina uccisa non a buonos aires nelle
favelas di buonos aires ma una bambina
uccisa in un conflitto a fuoco nel cuore
di una delle città più importanti
d'europa
napoli ecco in questa slide che partita
in anticipo
c'è un mercato
sul lato destro sinistro vostro c'è un
mercato è un quadro di un pittore che mi
ha regalato per la copertina del mio
libro
e allora poi questa sera perché queste
storie accadono sempre da un'altra parte
non accadono mai dove stiamo noi
accadono a casal di principe come questa
allora poi stasera immaginate di essere
un venditore ambulante
immaginate di aver preparato il vostro
furgone
la sera prima di andare a letto con la
vostra merci e di essere pronti domani
mattina le 4 a partire percorrere 100 km
per raggiungere l'area del mercato dove
pianterete la vostra bancarella e
immaginate di fare ritorno a casa senza
avere guadagnato una lira ma non perché
la vostra merce non vale niente
non perché una giornata di pioggia come
questa e la gente preferisce rimanere a
casa piuttosto che venire al mercato a
fare spese no immaginate di essere uno
di quegli ambulanti che percorrendo la
strada per raggiungere il mercato trovi
le vie d'accesso al piazzale dove il
comune dice che tu devi lavorare e trovi
le strade sbarrate da uomini
incappucciati armati di mitra e di
pistola
signori miei questo non è un film questa
è la realtà e vi dicono da qui passi
solo se tu accetti le mie regole scende
a patti con me chi ha voglia desiderio e
necessità di lavorare deve pagare deve
scandire i tempi delle tangenti e i
tempi degli agenti sono per la camorra
natale pasqua e ferragosto
se tu accetti di pagare
all'epoca stiamo parlando del 1992
e chi se la ricorda questa storia si
pagavano 500 mila lire a natale a pasqua
ea capodanno
però voi siete sempre quel venditore
ambulante e fate ancora uno sforzo di
immaginazione
se mentre siete presso la vostra
bancarella si presenta lì davanti a voi
dopo che voi avete pagato tutte le tasse
per esercitare quella professione al
comune si presenta verso la vostra
bancarella un uomo che indossa la divisa
del disonore e quindi si presenta con la
forza con la capacità di essere un
pubblico ufficiale ma anche con la
capacità intimidatrice che gli deriva da
essere anche un esponente del clan
e allora voi capite bene perché
quest'uomo si chiamava federico del
prete decide di buttare il cuore oltre
l'ostacolo e di fare la cosa giusta
denunciare queste angherie alle autorità
lui non può sopportare perché quest'uomo
ha sette figli e non può tornare a casa
lasciando 500 mila lire sulla bancarella
e nelle mani del vigile urbano che lo
taglieggiavano vedete questo gesto
importante porterà federico del prete
dritto nella tomba
lui lo sa
lo intuiscono anche i suoi familiari
chi non percepisce il pericolo sono solo
le autorità preposte
ecco perché lo chiamo l'ambulante solo
federico del prete aveva scoperchiato
una serie di interessi della camorra che
andavano oltre il mercato federico del
prete però aveva scoperto il traffico
delle buste di plastica una cosa
insignificante
chi l'avrebbe mai pensato che la camorra
potesse avere interessi anche sulle
buste di plastica
ecco lui scoperchiò anche questo affare
che fruttava milioni di lire all'epoca
ed oggi un gruppo di ragazzi ben
sostenuti tra cui il figlio di federico
del prete insieme a un altro orfano di
mimmo noviello un altro imprenditore
coraggioso anche lui ucciso qualche anno
dopo dalla camorra hanno realizzato una
startup facendo una cooperativa per
fornire a noi la busta la busta giusta
ecco federico del prete fu ucciso la
sera del 18 di febbraio del 2002 a casal
di principe in via baracca
il giorno dopo avrebbe dovuto
testimoniare al processo contro il
vigile urbano che passando tra le
bancarelle usava la parola d'ordine mimì
prepara la maglia era il segnale che
dovevano cacciare i soldi ecco federico
del prete aveva passione aveva la
passione per la libertà ed ora
cambiamo città
cambiamo luogo e andiamo a napoli il
cuore dell'europa
una delle città più importanti d'italia
credo che sia alla terza e anche qui voi
immaginate di chiamarvi giovanni
giovanni durante e di vivere a napoli in
un quartiere periferico del centro
storico perché questi sono i quartieri
del centro della città di napoli sono
periferie
nonostante le bellezze e allora
immaginate che sia un sabato sera
immaginate che abbiate appena terminato
di cenare e che all'improvviso sentiate
dei colpi di pistola dei colpi dei
rumori che non sono assolutamente dei
petardi fatti esplodere per festeggiare
una delle poche partite delle poche
vittorie della vostra squadra di calcio
non vi potete sbagliare sono quelli che
sentite sono colpi di pistola e allora
il vostro pensiero corre subito ad
annalisa per quei colpi di pistola
vengono dalla strada
pensate a vostra figlia che si chiama
analizza e uscita è scesa da poco
siete già presi dallo sconforto non
sapete cosa fare con un po di ansia vi
affacciate alla finestra andate verso la
finestra vi affacciate guardate giù e
vedete vostra figlia stesa per terra e
vi chiedete che cosa possa essere
successo e quindi vi precipitate giù per
le scale arrivate giù per strada e
vedete vostra figlia stesa per terra con
il corpo supino alla testa chinata
voi volete ancora sperare che sia solo
caduto e invece no non è caduta la
prendete la bracciate e mentre cercate
di riami animarla di sporcate le mani
del suo sangue
e allora che fate urlate in preda allo
sconforto perdete i sensi venite quando
vi riprendete vi dicono che vostra
figlia di appena 14 anni è stata colpita
alla testa da un colpo di pistola che
non era diretto neanche a lei
e allora a uccidere analizza una sera di
primavera del 2004 fu il rampollo di un
clan che spadroneggiava indisturbato nel
panorama criminale napoletana da più di
50 anni
ecco cosa avrei fatto io se mi fossi
chiamato giovanni durante
cosa avreste fatto voi io sarei scappato
da quell'inferno di strada che forcella
sarei scappato da quell'inferno di città
e invece no giovanni un uomo del popolo
di quel popolo sceglie di rimanere
rimane lì e dopo aver donato
generosamente gli organi della figlia
egli fa di più convince rompe il muro di
omertà che c'è a forcella dicendo a
tutti quelli che avevano visto quello
che era accaduto di parlare e così
succede
accade che in questura vadano
spontaneamente che di solito ci andava
con le manette giovanni rompe il muro di
omertà ma fa ancora di più giovanni
rimane lì
annalisa è morta e stata ammazzata al
civico 22 di via vicaria vecchia
forcella al 23 c'è un cinema chiuso da
30 anni con le saracinesche crivellate
di colpi
lui lo sa prendila su quella saracinesca
dentro quella a quel a quelle ex cinema
ci costruisce una biblioteca diffusa
capisce che mettere in mano al ragazzo
un libro piuttosto che una pistola
quel ragazzo avrà sicuramente un'altra
vita in solitudine in solitudine
giovanni fa questo fino a quando non
arriva benigni a dire che ad
apostrofarlo come un importante esempio
di ricostruzione perché ha saputo tirare
fuori il miele dalla morte
ecco io adesso quel super cinema sta per
diventare qualcosa di molto più bello
abbiamo un progetto io adesso vi posso
dire
si chiama così forcella bit
non vi posso dire cos'è altro forse
l'anno prossimo qualcun altro racconterà
cos'è questa esperienza ma sicuramente
vi posso dire che la stiamo facendo con
passione questa attività perché annalisa
poteva ancora volare e adesso vediamo un
breve filmato
finito
[Musica]
a napoli si può morire per un colpo di
pistola
magari neanche destinato a te e si
lascia un vuoto
come quello lasciato da annalisa durante
uccisa a 14 anni queste strade una sera
di primavera del 2004
[Musica]
un vuoto infinito che niente può colmare
ma è la cultura può combattere
[Musica]
un libro può aiutare a capire e capirai
da salvare una vita
a salvare il mondo
a colmare un vuoto
[Musica]
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]